you know what an injustice fancies that
injustice twos coming out he's gonna
talk about it just funny because when we
got the first the reveal trailer for
injustice to a bunch people were like
talk about it then like the next day was
III and then people asked started asking
me about other stuff so much to do
videos on so little time so you couldn't
have to pick a Jews I'm picking
injustice to I guess someone justice
gods among us was a fighting game
created by the creators of Mortal Kombat
but there were all DC characters in this
fighting game has some solid DC comic
fanservice and a cool story within the
campaign so that was actually really
cool and I think there would be an
injustice to but there are interesting
things in here some things I like some
things I'm concerned about I don't know
if they're going to actually be
realities so let's just do a video about
it you don't know what's facts why not
just do a video about it that's how you
get your justification in the reveal
trailer we saw the characters started
getting like their suits would turn into
armor and things we're getting upgraded
their appearance kept changing and I
guess that's a whole mechanic in this
game is that you unlock gear and you can
outfit your fighter with said gear every
guess it's really customizable it's like
someone might have the same cape that
you have or the same s but I'm gonna
have the same gauntlet
I guess there's going to be a lot of
unlocks to unlock and injustice to and
the boast that they're selling as long
as they're like well odds are when you
fight someone online they're Aquaman's
gonna look different than your Aquaman
so right there it says there's going to
be a lot of unlocks which is great I
love the fact that this appears like
they're concentrating on unlocks in the
game rather than UDL say using in a way
to you know like motivate you like I
would unlock the thing however as cool
as it is in the concept of holy crap you
can unlock somebody like you I stopped
playing the game you're going to want to
do those logistics that get you the the
new Superman belts or the Batman I
probably should have said belt for
Batman that's Superman utility belt you
know they're gonna have DLC Packers like
oh it's an exclusive flash symbol for
his chest so you can only get the DLC or
if you pre-ordered the game at your
local game store you're gonna get some
exclusive unlocks there too however it
is great to have unlocks in a fighting
game just a big part about what makes
fighting games fun for me the whole gear
system they're going for is actually
really cool for a fighting game I like
the fact that it's like RPG elements
trickling into a fighting game visually
customizable as well as your fighting
style customizable because they also
said it's not just going to be stat
buffs and defense or whatnot it's gonna
unlock different moves for you so your
Superman is going
you fight differently than someone
else's Superman online it's like the
customization of the three fighting
styles of Mortal Kombat acts times a lot
more great possibilities there as long
as it's executed well but the thing
about that is as cool as it is to be
able to outfit your Superman or your
Aquaman or your Flash to what you want
him to look like I personally like
playing as the comic book characters
from the comic book novelty you know
when justice one was like alright that's
the Arkham City Joker skin or The
Killing Joke Joker or the tourist Joker
from The Killing Joke you know I like
being able to play as characters from
the story arcs in the comic books that
they're from now I imagine they're gonna
have elements of it like all right
here's the Killing Joke Joker hat you
might get a hat he might be able to have
a camera accessory he might have a
Hawaiian shirt I feel like in the end if
he was up against The Killing Joke Joker
he would notice a difference you know
it'd be like in city of villains when
people were like I made shredder in city
Avilla for those of you who don't
remember city of villains it's an MMO
with super heroes and super villains so
you know someone makes shredder and it
was a really cool shredder for having
the gear you had but it was actually
screen accurate too shredder I don't
want to see them compromise the ability
to have really cool novelty skins from
comic book arcs and stories for having
their own gear that won't actually do
that for you they do have personalised
dialogue between the two characters that
are going to fight like Mortal Kombat X
I thought that was pretty cool the end
card like the victory clips were like a
Batman wins to fight them Batman will do
something cool if you're like Batman
wins but in all of the ones I saw in the
gameplay trailer that looks kind of
boring example Batman like throws
batarangs at the screen and they'll
freeze and go slow-mo which is a cool
pose in and of itself as a possibility
but what's cooler that or an injustice
one word Batman was like stay down but
he's prowling the rooftops of Gotham now
and I'm just saying of the two of them I
feel like prowling the rooftops of
Gotham a little cooler than throwing
batarangs at the camera a couple things
I want will are first of all guys John
Constantine I've been pining for him
since injustice one let's just have him
I do like the character customization as
long as we also have the alternate skins
from the novelty of the comic book
stories that we actually know and love
so we can have that nostalgia trip in
that fanservice for us so this is my
thoughts on injustice 2 as it stands now
again this is just what I assessed from
a couple things that Ed Boon and company
said
and from the gameplay trailer and the
reveal trailer won't know until some
months down the road where they actually
break down exactly how all of this works
and I definitely won't know until I play
the game in the end guys I am excited
for injustice 2 for sure I mean other
than the little gripes that are
ultimately probably just the baseless
paranoia's of a nerd rambling on YouTube
they're doing something seemingly very
cool with injustice too and I want to
see it in action funny thing is in the
reveal trailer for injustice 2 there was
a narrator who was Bryan Cranston's if
it were like woah is Bryan Cranston in
this game who is he playing
little known fact Bryan Cranston played
Jim Gordon in Batman year one so is it
going to be Jim Gordon can Jim Gordon
really hold his own and injustice look
JK Simmons who plays the new Jim Gordon
in the new movies is any indication yes
Jim Gordon can hold his own and
injustice did you see that [ __ ] oh my
god old guy is super inspiring me to
work out right now so when justice to
have you seen what they have so far and
what do you think about what you've seen
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more